the rook goes fine goes to the a line he
should have come here three four moves
ago yeah
the black rook it could have started
checking ages ago maybe queen now and
that's just maybe maybe queening is just
winning yeah there we go he gives up one
pawn to deflect the black king away now
the black king cannot stop the entry of
the white king it's just game over this
game you can't stop the pawn uh the
bishop's gonna block the bishop can come
in support the pawn black's pawns can't
move because that won't pass on look at
ding yeah he smiles he sits back and
sips some water incredible gain pure
panic from
uh yeah yeah i i think i love those
games
i mean just because they're so exciting
right i mean like they're human right
you know to arise to humor to be human
but we should explain why white is
winning now black has to give up his
rook for the white pawn and the white
bishop
all of black's pawns stand on the light
squares as well white's bishop will
eventually win them and there we go we
have a result wow what a crazy game mama
yara he was almost about to make a
comeback